let's get the latest information tonight
from dr anthony fauci of the national
institutes of allergy and infectious
disease dr fauci always good to see you
so
as phil mentioned phase three trials of
the new moderna vaccine began
6 45 this morning with the first of 30
000 patients getting
what will be one of two shots 28 days
apart what will you be looking for
during these phase three trials well the
the phase three
charles john is that the major uh
question
is does it work it isn't effective and
that's exactly what we're looking for
obviously
you want to look for safety concerns
also but the main
issue here is you vaccinate
15 000 people will get the vaccine 15
000 will get a placebo and then you
determine
the difference in infection with the
coronavirus
in each of those groups so it's a
two-ohm study as you said
correctly it's a prime followed by a
boost
28 days later and hopefully within a
period
of a few months we'll be able to get a
signal to know whether it actually is
effective
in preventing infection with the
coronavirus it's it's extraordinary
circumstance john because this is the
fastest
that we have ever gone from the
identification of a new virus
doing the sequence getting a vaccine and
going into a phase three trial for
efficacy
and we've done it by increased
technologies that have really been
transforming the way we do vaccine
trials well necessity is the mother of
all invention based on the initial data
dr fatchi how optimistic are you that
you will get what you're looking for
from this modern vaccine
you know john if you look at the the
results from the phase one trial albeit
a relatively small number of individuals
the vaccine induced in those individuals
a level of antibody neutralizing
antibody which is the
hallmark of protection at levels that
were at least
as good and in some cases better than
what you would see
from people who were convalescing from
natural infection
so even though the numbers of people
were small the fact that you can induce
a response
that mimics what you do with natural
infection
is good news so that makes me cautiously
optimistic
that we may have something here but it's
going to take a few months
to determine whether or not we do in the
early days of the vaccine development dr
fauci you laid out that the
the government was going to do things
differently here that it was going to
proactively start to
build up a supply the president talked
about that
earlier today let's listen what he said
we're mass producing all of the most
promising vaccine candidates in advance
so that on the day one that it's
approved
it'll be available to the american
people immediately and we'll probably
have a lot for a lot of other people
throughout the world the world is
suffering from this
giant virus as we mentioned that that's
a departure from the way that things
normally go you usually don't scale up
until after
phase three trials are over and then
you've got that six month lag so that
will get it out there
quickly but a lot of people have a
question as to
who will get it first right it's a good
question john and what we're going to do
is we're going to take that very
seriously
there are committees that are formed to
make a recommendation
of getting the vaccine out equitably to
the people
who would benefit from it most and that
is not something that you take lightly
so what will happen
is that there will be a prioritization
hopefully as we get into 2021 john
we'll have enough vaccine for everyone
who needs it but early on
when you first start distributing it
we're not going to have
everything for everyone sure what you'll
do is probably have people
who could benefit the most and those who
are most vulnerable for example
first responders the people are going to
be putting themselves at risk
taking care of patients with covert 19
those who are vulnerable the elderly
those with underlying conditions
because we know now from sad experience
that individuals have underlying
conditions are much more likely
to have a serious negative outcome from
infection
president trump talked the other day
about potentially having people get the
first shots in september maybe october
which has led some people to say oh is
this going to be an october surprise in
the political campaign
here's what the secretary of hhs alex
azar said about that earlier
there's no politics in any of this we
need therapeutics and we need vaccines
and we need them as quickly as we can
get them
and we are working to mit to basically
shave every day off the development and
manufacturing that we can do
that we can that we can do so and but
we're going to make sure that any
therapeutic or
any vaccine is safe and effective up to
the fda's
gold standards so dr fauci obviously you
want to get a vaccine out there as
quickly as possible
is there any political pressure to get
this out there before november the third
and
any are any corners being cut in order
to do that
well certainly there are no corners
being cut john i'll guarantee you that
safety is very important what we're
doing is not compromising safety
and certainly not compromising
scientific integrity
we in fact briefed the president today
about this
in the oval office and there is no
political pressure
that i've seen it all to move quickly
the the the speed of the trial
and how quickly you get the results is
dependent upon certain factors
one is the number of infections that you
get within the context of the trial
to determine if it works or not so if we
go out there we're going to have 30
000 people in the trial 15 000 will get
the
vaccine and 15 000 would be placebo if
you look at the accrual and the rate of
accrual
that you could project that you'll get
an answer sometime
in the mid to late fall that could be
november that could be october it's
very very difficult to predict it's
going to be
the infection rate and the people who
get vaccinated
are they within that group something we
can predict
dr fauci we've got about 30 seconds left
phil keating mentioned
that there has been the beginning of a
plateauing of some of the spike that
we've seen in states like texas
arizona and florida what do you think is
responsible for that
and does that bode well for not having
to roll back the reopening that we've
seen
well certainly you like to see when you
get surges like that which were very
disturbing john
that you begin to see them plateau that
means hopefully people are starting to
do the fundamental things
that we've been telling them to do about
mask wearing
avoiding crowds closing the bars
health you know hand hygiene etc
hopefully and i believe it is
now having an impact we've got to make
sure that other states
that are starting to show an uptick do
what we're talking about
before you get the major surge otherwise
we're going to be repeating what we saw
in some of those southern states
which would really be a shame if that
happens all right well everybody's got
to do their part we should mention you
know we
we talked with you last week about your
debut throwing out the first pitch
we've got a a frame of that at the
nationals park and we should also point
out
that you now have the top selling
baseball card in history
51 512 cards sold in 24 hours there's
the card from tops
50 years from now you could be the next
hoeness wagner we'll see
dr fauci great to see you thanks so much
great to see you john thanks